[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATIE RICHARDSON: We have many
people from diverse backgrounds
who are getting certified.
But what we find is that,
especially for individuals
who are interested
in certifications,
it could be that
they are looking
to go into a new job role or
just upscale in a certain area.
They want to demonstrate that
they are skilled in something
specific and not
only demonstrate
that to their peers, but also
to potential future employers.
So really, I think it's
about career advancement.
But also, it can be more,
I think, self-motivated,
where you just want to
prove to yourself that you
have these skills.
Maybe you've been studying
something for a period of time.
You've been completing trainings
or practicing something
on your own.
And getting that certification
is kind of that milestone--
proof that you
have those skills.
Certifications in particular
can be used by individuals
to learn new skills, motivate
themselves to learn new skills,
find a new job, move
into a new area that's
interesting to them.
And so our goal is to help
signal to the industry,
or maybe just to
their teams if they're
staying within
their same job role,
that they have specific
skills, that they
have met this standard for the
industry and for that job role.
So that recognition, the
career advancement, but also
the just intrinsic
validation for yourself
that you have the skills that
you need to do your job well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]